[Musique]
et en parallèle de cette exposition la
commanderie des Templiers accueille un
dispositif numérique où vous êtes invité
à danser et c'est Mélanie poqu qui va
nous en parler bonjour Mélanie bonjour
Camille alors c'est Flo 612 c'est son
nom ça a été imaginé par Daniel larieux
un chorégraphe français et c'est une
installation à danser comme vous l'avez
dit Camille un projet chorégraphique
fait par les enfants avec les élèves de
l'école pierrebudin à Paris mais c'est
surtout fait pour les enfants de 6 à 12
ans plus exactement d'ailleurs c'est de
là que que vient le 612 je laisse agès
Coutard qui est danseuse de la compagnie
de Daniel larieux vous en dire un peu
plus elle était au micro de Michel
lorau Daniel larieux l'a conçu vraiment
dans un espace de liberté c'est-à-dire
que quand les enfants rentrent dans
cette boîte ils n'ont aucune consigne
ils peuvent danser ils peuvent marcher
courir bouger ou alors ils peuvent juste
contempler le décor donc c'est vraiment
un un espace de liberté pour eux mais
alors comment ça fonctionne en fait il y
a des capteurs 48 au total qui vont
réagir au mouvement ces capteurs vont
notamment modifier la lumière et la
musique alors dans la boîte on trouve
une toile de 17 m avec des décors de
jungle imaginaire des feuilles des
végétaux principalement et chaque
lumière fait apparaître de nouveaux
éléments sur la toile c'est ça qui est
le plus impressionnant regardez cet
extrait2
[Musique]
pour tenter l'aventure flow 612 et
pourquoi pas se découvrir des talents de
danseur rendez-vous à la Commanderie des
Templiers jusqu'au mai merci Mélanie de
nous avoir présenté ce dispositif et on
passe maintenant à notre agenda